my first met Richard Donner he was known
as the macho director of Superman and
the old man and not to mention numerous
TV westerns and cup shows so it was kind
of a ironic but unbelievably lucky that
the movie that brought us together was
this lush romantic fantasy and even more
ironic that it was the love story that
attracted dick and me to the script
little did we know that the project was
going to provide us with our own love
story I have to thank Alan Ladd jr.
because I was just a nobody producer I
had done a TV movie which was
well-received and mr. mom but you know I
couldn't get to did honor so thank you
so laddy got the script to dick Donner
so we started now we're going right and
we start prepping ladyhawk in 1981 in
soviet-controlled Czechoslovakia and
this is where dick and I started our
friendship I was you know I was young
female producer and I got to say that
many of the other men were just simply
trying to push me out of the room and I
fought back because that's my nature but
you know who had my back
dick Donner and he would which is really
not surprising if you know dick he's the
defender of the underdog so I was
fighting but I had this he is so I was
fighting to stay in there but I had the
800-pound gorilla behind me ha ha as for
Czechoslovakia so they had really
beautiful castles but this was predate
aunt and ultimately we just found it too
difficult to shoot there so we go back
to California we're working on the
script
dick has us conduct our meetings where
else by the pool with dick in the pool
so privately before I don't even know if
you know this dick i forbade the writers
to go on the pool I said we don't go in
there - what meeting and / and so what
we were because dick was easily
distracted if you know dick you know
that ultimately the great Tom mango
through wrote the script and we had our
movie to make
so after Czechoslovakia didn't work out
and dick went off to direct a toy
we looked elsewhere in the world we came
up with Italy in 1983 saw us returning
and prepping in this time in Rome so
here's just a few tidbits we wanted Mick
Jagger to play the bishop but Fox
wouldn't let us hire him we hired the
great John Wood instead which was just
fine Kurt Russell were supposed to play
Navarre but he miss Goldie and Rutger
Howard filled those shoes since we were
in Rome already we needed an Isabeau
Michelle Pfeiffer self taped her
audition with this little-known actor
Kevin Costner reading the role that the
wonderful Matthew Broderick finally
played and at the end of the audition
she said LT Ditka I have an idea of what
Ladyhawke looks like the camera camera
goes black open up there's the chair and
there's a little parakeet sitting on the
chair it wasn't Michele's voice and
because she has a sense of humor Dickson
that's the one that's so we also got to
work with the amazing Leo Kern and a lot
of you have worked with dick know that
he also always cast his friends and
family so the fabulous Steve Cain who's
here today and who you saw played the
bishops guard of course he's credited as
Stephano Hurwitz him and the credits
thanks today so during the final weeks
of prep my then husband and I were
having serious problems and two weeks
into filming we were divorcing I was
devastated and my friend dick Donner
comforted me first thing he did was
throw me into his pool was all my
clothes on and let me just stop right
there and say that during the 1981 prep
dick shared his enormous house on Chaney
walk in London with me and they are
witnessed firsthand the amount of women
chasing Richard Donner and it was
mind-boggling and I already decided
right then and there I could never be
with a man like that
so now we're in Rome two years later and
after comforting me about mark my
husband he swooped in and I couldn't
resist but I didn't want anybody to know
because it you know it was tough being a
female I was 33 and I was trying to get
respect and I didn't want to be sleeping
with the director so we snuck around
which was kind of really exciting and I
think you know I'll help things out all
right so enough about us back to Rome
the great Vittorio Storaro was to be our
cinematographer and for me it was the
first time I witnessed firsthand the
visual prepping of a movie with movie
greats
Vittorio showed us for hours his images
for the movie from visible blue from
Disney movies to Caravaggio lighting for
the night I learned so much from dick
that year I learned that I learned and I
took with me
key secrets about how to work with
actors for example okay we were going to
shoot the scene and and we're setting up
for these beautiful woods but they were
a little dark so Victoria was setting up
the lights but it was scripted the
location was scripted exterior open
field and what an actor came to dick and
said that he couldn't shoot the scene in
that location because it was written in
an open field he just couldn't perform
the scene there I'm getting angry of
course but dick
I watched him very patiently understand
that it was a scene itself that was
bothering the actor not the location and
I saw dick work with him and find an
understanding and understand that the
actors need to be assured and therefore
after that it all went smoothly and the
scene can look great we had a few
problems with a wolf Michelle Pfeiffer
was not allowed to walk with it which we
didn't know but so once we started
filming it was the wolf trainer who was
about 70 pounds 75 pounds heavier than
Michelle who you see from behind with
the wolf hence the long black cloak and
the claw
it's a hawk on rutgers arm would smack
rugger in the face every time he sail
hein while the horse underneath them
which was not a trained movie horse it
was a different it was like a show horse
would go from side to side because
Einstein anyway I could go on forever
about the experience of dick directing
he kids keeps him super happy set he
pumps everybody up when he goes hip hop
hip hop hip hop and then he sets an
example with his own indomitable energy
he'd walk on the set and you know why am
I always waiting and but you know he was
so experienced he knew everybody's job
and appreciated them and encouraged them
to give him ideas and enable them to do
their best and let me tell you dick
Donner directing is truly the sexiest
man alive
surely he should be on the cover of
People magazine over the years I've
realized that 99% of the time I believe
that the directors personality gets on
the screen and that is how I hire
directors and if you look at Dick's
movies dick is fun
larger than life loud strong with a big
mushy heart so I will tell you that not
a day goes by that his infectious
booming laughter doesn't make me and
everybody around me smile his confidence
his fearlessness his humor I would make
people adore him and has wrapped around
me like a protective cloak suffice it to
say that the combination of learning
moviemaking from Richard Donner and
falling in love with them has made me
personally and professionally a better
producer and a happier loving person in
many ways ladyhawk is our own kind of
personal love story on the Hawks indict
the wolf for personal and professional
reasons I didn't really think that we
could be together but fortunately the
spell was broken and we've been together
34 years
you